I mean we can say they've gone Rogue in
terms of War when was the last time the
US declared war they've gone Rogue in
basically every way you can imagine it
they don't they don't they don't take
care of the Border they violate
individual's rights by spying on them we
the I don't believe that the NSA has
stopped spying even though there's
they're supposed to have stopped
collecting metadata I don't believe they
are and the reason I don't believe they
are is because if they want they let
Google and and all the the companies
these big tech companies they let them
collect the data and then just subpoena
it so they don't their hands are clean
but if they want it you they know that
these big tech companies are going to
give it to them so they're monitoring
everything you do ring will will monitor
you with with cameras at your house
there's cameras all over every major
city the the number of individual
liberties that are specifically
protected by the Constitution is equal
to the number of individual liberties
that the federal government violates on
a regular basis